hey guys my name is Jess it is cheese
day and I first like to thank our us
colleagues for covering for us yesterday
while we were doing a 24 hour long shift
of our extra life last room where we did
hit our goal but now we're all rested up
and we're ready for gang sweat news is
that's everything so have a good day
we're at the beginning oh let's do it
okay gonna sleep now
they might have already call this info
on our attempted GameSpot news roundup
on our sleep-deprived live stream but
animal pocket Pocket Edition pocket camp
the farm it's out watching a day earlier
than we expected at two animal crossing
pocket camp is now available for free
worldwide on both iOS and Android
Australia already had it so and I can
assure you that the vast majority of you
will probably play it for like four
hours religiously and then never touch
it again just like the majority of the
GameSpot Australia team some players are
reporting that the game is unstable
right now and throwing up occasional
connection errors even though it's
technically live you can expect a lot of
familiar animal crossing features like
collecting items making friends and
deciding who in town you do and don't
like the game does include
microtransactions in the form of leaf
tickets which you can use to speed up
your progress they can also be acquired
through game play it's almost
Thanksgiving in the US and that means
it's almost time for Black Friday sales
yes and Microsoft are getting on board
by reducing the price of starting
memberships to the Xbox game past 21.1
dole say they've added some pretty sweet
games that's right the Xbox game passed
which gives you instant access to over
100 Xbox one and Xbox 360 games on your
Xbox one well alpha a started membership
between November 17th and 27th for $1 to
sweeten the deal there are also some new
games coming to the subscription service
in December only Xbox one side you can
roadie run through Gears of War for play
zelda by the way of the band disturbed
with Darksiders wall master edition
solve crimes and hit those opiates in
sherlock holmes the devil's daughter
make hard decisions and fight for
survival in this war of mine
the little ones and throw Eddie do you
throw in La Crosse
yes sir my throwings okay throw a ball
in Casey Powell across 16 Mega Man 10
we'll also be coming to the service as
well as the backwards-compatible 360
version of the fantastic Mass Effect if
you came to know where to get the best
bargains this holiday be sure to head on
over to GameSpot and check out our many
many sales guides and don't front those
of you who aren't in the US many digital
storefronts also take part so hopefully
there's something for you there to
finally Square Enix released an outline
of their results briefing that they held
on November 8th and there's some pretty
interesting stuff in there particularly
in regard to Nintendo switch during a
Q&A reported by komatsu Square Enix
president Yosuke Matsuda responded to a
question asking where they intend to
prioritize allocation of development
resources by saying we base our
development resource allocations on the
unique attributes of each platform in
particular Nintendo's which makes it
easier for us to leverage our back
catalog of assets and expertise so we
want to be proactive in creating new IP
and rebooting past titles for that
platform he also added that another
reason they want to be proactive in
their development efforts for the switch
is that it's a console which suits the
mid-size titles that the publisher tends
toward that is everything we've got for
you today thanks so much for joining us
once again and do remember to leave us
your comments in that comment section
down below we'll see you guys tomorrow I
had I had a feather on me in this Hong
time button cap has everything happy
today okay now you can do the end part
at the start